c'est génial de dire qu'on est quand
même en train de représenter les jeux
olympiques c'est c'est important que
c'est trop bien c'est tout cas rien de
cochon un point on est impatient on
attend et on sera derrière l'équipe des
profs à la sauce pourtant paris 2024 ce
n'est que dans trois ans et pourtant
l'engouement est déjà présent
athlètes et nous ont déambulé sur la
piste du vélodrome nationale dans leurs
mains les drapeaux des comités
olympiques paralympiques et de paris
2024 qui faisaient étape à montigny le
bretonneux ce 18 septembre le compte à
rebours des jeux en france a bien
démarré se veut vraiment dire que ça y
est on y est on est pays en est le pays
de l'olympisme pour les pays du
paralympiques mme on a attendu longtemps
on a même attendu un an de plus en cause
de l'aco vide des jeux qui se
dérouleront également sur le territoire
saint quentinois vélodrome mais aussi
golf national à guyancourt et la colline
à elancourt comme sites olympiques
l'agglomération se prépare
qu'est ce qui est plus beau que de le
réveiller l'envi de donner envie à
quelqu'un de se dépasser c'est le top
c'est une fois en plus tous les siècles
on peut la voir on est très fiers surya
pour saint quentin
d'y être associés aussi directement
cette cérémonie des drapeaux étaient le
moment aussi de croiser les sportifs qui
rêvent de paris 2024 l'apparat
triathlète cécile sabouraud les pistards
quentin lafargue quentin caleyron timmy
gillion et florian gringo tout
fraîchement médaillé de bronze en
vitesse par équipes c'était l'occasion
pour lui de fêter avec le public présent
sur tokyo on n'avait pas forcément le
public eh ben ça montre qu'on est
soutenu et c'est je jouais jamais dire
depuis le retour en france c'est là
qu'on se rend compte vraiment ce que
sont les jeux olympiques et on se rend
compte que c'est quelque chose qui
touche tout le monde qui touche vraiment
tout tout pays donc vraiment content
vraiment fier pouvoir partager tout ça
les drapeaux olympique doivent circuler
dans une trentaine de villes en france
prochaine étape dans les yvelines le 16
octobre sur la colline d'elancourt